there's a meme at the moment of the sort
of Lone Wolf Sigma male guy that's
making great things happen on his own
I'm pretty sure that you are the footage
that's used over the top of a lot of
these Sigma memes in any case could you
do this on your own no no none of it I
couldn't do my YouTube without Calvin I
couldn't have started my businesses
without Maddie I couldn't be doing raw
supplements without Dom and Matt who are
my partners in that I wouldn't be the
man who I am without my dad I wouldn't
be able to have gotten through my stress
as a teenager without my sister I
wouldn't have gotten through the last
four Olympians without Courtney I almost
get emotional thinking about it but when
I like reflect back on like what I'm
most grateful for it's always the people
in my life and I'm so lucky it's like
crazy the people I have in my life are
everything in the relationships I like
build mean the world to me
I literally like Cry Sometimes by myself
like doing like a gratitude reflection
or something relationships in my life
are everything I know I wouldn't be
where I am without it and I would never
be the one to think I could do it all by
myself